the New England Patriots as of right now
where things stand I was getting into
this mode earlier this week where the
Patriots a team that despite anyone who
doubts them despite any adversity
they've encountered they've got playoff
experience they're gonna find a way to
win they're gonna pull it all together
where are they right now after
everything that's happened this week do
you mean prior to Sunday you felt that
no because I did well I thought it was
gonna be a galvanizing situation where
they played better than they had but
because of operator error they lost and
I thought they'd say you know what okay
time to cut the crap let's go to
Pittsburgh where we've had great success
against the team that we're smarter than
and more disciplined then and do what we
do and they couldn't do it they think
that's the problem like is they they
can't do it it's not that they're unable
to and I think that we look at the
penalties and the drops that they had
against Pittsburgh at least around here
and people are saying that you know this
is something that they can control it's
not the Steelers it's not the Dolphins
it's not the Titans it's Patriots
showing up Platt but I think that there
are more holes in the dike than there
are
fingers that they can use to plug them
at this juncture and we got 14 games of
evidence dad but doesn't it all change
though Tom doesn't I mean we've seen
this before where we write them off and
I know that typically happens in
September but when we write them off
they find a way to get it done and as we
get to the single elimination round when
you consider the experience this team
has every year for the past eight well
seven could be eight this year getting
to the AFC Championship game I go by
every every season back to 2010 you know
and having all those playoff games that
go along with it and Tom Brady with 37
career playoff games doesn't that give
them an advantage despite any flaws any
issues when you get into a game with the
Chiefs if you get into a game with your
team that doesn't have that experience
doesn't that give the Patriots an edge
that we're overlooking at this point a
hundred percent and you you've groped
that earlier this week but once the game
starts and you get on the field
if you don't get
the reassurance by having success by
getting off the field on third down by
being able to stop the run by being able
to pick up key third downs yourself then
that goes away the experience doesn't
matter and the Patriots have struggled
to do those things they've struggled to
run the ball consistently even though
they can be an explosive running team at
times now right now you have you just
lost Josh Gordon so in comes Phillip
Dorsett maybe a bigger role now for
cordarrelle Patterson cordarrelle
Patterson is a special teams player who
the team has done a good job and he's
done a good job of finding places to be
relevant he is not what you would call a
conventional wide receiver he's gonna
have a bigger role Dorsett has been
marginalized because of Gordon's
emergence Edelman's that feed her to the
point where you know he's not able to
accelerate Gronk is gonna see more
attention because Gordon's gone Chris
Hogan is just you know okay third
receiver people lose track of him and he
scores touchdowns and it was give him
the ball because he doesn't get open so
they're not what they were that's that's
the problem
in it you know it's experienced as
someone is Michael Jordan's probably
more experienced than anybody in the NBA
but he's not going to be able to go out
there and compete right now because of
factors that are beyond the control of
experience yeah but but Tom look you say
we've got 14 games of evidence the
Patriots were nine and three before that
a fluke finish against Miami which would
have pushed them to 10 and three there's
only one game recently that is alarming
and that's the Steelers game because
we're so used to Bill Belichick and Tom
Brady going in and handling the
Pittsburgh Steelers we're not used to
seeing the Patriots get handled when you
say there's 14 games of evidence I just
look they were nine and three right they
know how to win games even with their
flaws and that's the point I keep coming
back to whatever warts are on this team
they know how to find ways to win and
I'm not going to doubt them going into
January because we've seen this before
where they can find a way to pull it all
together get the right game plan get the
right execution situational football but
I understand the past two weeks
there have been a lot of flaws in that
regard which would cause us to believe
this is the beginning of a trend
they've also scored you know the
Pittsburgh game they've basically scored
three points if it wasn't for the three
guys going with Gordon and nobody going
with Hogan offensively they squid ten
points in Tennessee they scored 10
points in Detroit they scored 20 with a
garbage time touchdown in the last
couple minutes against Jacksonville they
have difficulties on the road if they
can't run the ball they're gonna be
having problems I hear what you're
saying Mike you know they can do it I'm
not gonna sit here and expect to go to a
game playoff games you know if they do
get a bye and they get Baltimore or
somebody here and they win and next
thing you know they're in the AFC
Championship at San Diego Kansas or
Kansas City and they're able to to
somehow get by those teams I mean that
can happen yeah but the likelihood isn't
just there's not a lot of mitigating
factors right now Mike that make me say
well if this happens people don't
understand the Patriots are going to get
crunk back are they gonna get Edelman
back 2015 remember they started out 10
and out Edelman got hurt Gronk was
diminished they finished two and four
down the stretch they lose the
home-field advantage they have to go to
Denver and play on the road but Edelman
came back for the playoffs and still
that team wasn't able to get over the
hump because it was still too diminished
right now this team isn't getting
players back they are what they are
they're the most healthy team in
football you wrote about earlier this
week so those things are real for how
long did they know that Josh Gordon was
on his way out I don't know whether they
knew during the past week I had a
conversation Wednesday you know and it
was indicated to me that Gordon so
what's what's going on with Gordon why
is he getting the balls like he said
he's regressing in terms of he's he's
retreating into himself he sees waling
people up he's not communicating he's
silent so why did ways that I was going
great social anxiety
was the answer I was given he just
having a hard time so that emerged this
week that was a conversation I had
Wednesday and then I get a Thursday and
he suspended so yes Tom you don't just
get suspended out of the blue that
percolates for a while you vote right
but what I'm saying is for some period
of time before yesterday before he
posted that he was stepping away from
football for a bit he knew he was
stepping away from football for a lot
longer than a bit and the team knew it
as well and I'm trying to I'm trying to
figure out whether or not the Patriots
were consciously detaching from him yeah
now I'm trying to figure out why he
wasn't on the field for fourth and 15 is
he not on the field for fourth and 15
because they know hey we got to get this
done the rest of the way without this
guy so let's let's see if the guys we
put out there like Cordell Patterson can
get it done because they're gonna have
to get it done at some point he did play
57 snaps that day and the explanation
given I thought was pretty coaching he
had just played a ton of snaps he's not
been in the best shape look I'm not
saying that they didn't know but I'm
just explaining on 4th and 15 with the
season and perhaps the home field
advantage et cetera seating on the line
they're not gonna say well let's see if
we can figure it out so I'm but I'm not
saying either that they would not I
don't think that they were in love with
his preparation last week just by what I
was the indications I was given as to
his demeanor over the recent past so why
did he get two targets displays 57 snaps
why did he only make one catch why did
Brady not go to him again after a drop
on third down we see him go away from
players before when he didn't feel as if
they were into it and maybe Josh Gordon
wasn't into it maybe the Patriots didn't
know Josh Gordon his agent did but for
whatever reason he only saw two targets
so I don't know Mike if the Patriots
knew or if they just weren't down with
the way he was prepared but something
was amiss over the last week with him
and that is borne out by
happen on Thursday yeah I mean the other
chance is he they just deliberately used
him as a decoy on Sunday because they
knew something was up and he's on the
field for 57 snaps and the Steelers have
to deal with them and based upon what
he'd done all year you can't just let
him run free all right I only have a
little time left but I want to focus on
an observation you had about Tom Brady
coming out of the Steelers game the idea
that that something's going on with him
that there's that that aversion to
contact I don't want to put words in
your mouth I want to get your thoughts
on what's going on with Brady is he
starting to get to the point where he's
getting hit too much he's he's conscious
of that and maybe he's getting rid of
the ball faster in order to avoid the
hits yeah we saw the fourth and 15 play
when you run it back he's falling away
as he delivers the ball and there's no
one really on him there's guys near him
and he's done that a lot this year where
he's kind of and it's always to his left
he falls away to his left so I did have
a chance to ask him about the locker
room because you know he takes hits he's
willing to pay stand in there generally
speaking so if he's going to be afraid
if that's the word that's even fair to
use with an NFL quarterback which
probably isn't but then that changes
things it's not just on those plays it
means what did the Patriots attach
themselves to when they traded Jimmy
Garoppolo is he gonna make it to forty
five house coaching staff regard him
Brady said look I've been getting hit
for 25 years believe me I'm not afraid I
saw something coming front side I've
seen that and I'm not gonna have the
game especially after the Miami halftime
situation I'm not going to have the game
and with the ball in my hands I was not
taking a sack in that situation so and
you can see we showed the clip we just
showed the clip and you can see he's got
somebody coming from his right now the
guy falls down but I think that's what
he thought was gonna be the guy who
crashed into him so that makes sense but
you know I've always been told about Tom
Brady that when it's time for him to go
it's gonna be because of his legs not
his arm that the leg the ability to get
away from contact the ability to avoid
the big hit once that goes and he starts
getting hit that's when it's all going
to crumble and that's why what you wrote
earlier this week caught my attention
because I've been waiting for that
moment where the
eggs are keeping him yemenese so even
though he's not a guy who's gonna run
north-south he's a guy who can move so
well in the pocket and step up and step
to the side and slide away and make good
decisions about when to throw the ball
once he loses that ability Tom that's
when we're gonna see the end yep and
when his feet are flat and planted and
he's able to step into the throws he's
got every bit of velocity arm strength
and ability that he needs but I think
the knee injury that he sustained again
to Tennessee you know he's better from
it he's lost the injury report with it
but those things limit you and I think
that the fact that guys can't uncover
for him gives him a lack of confidence
it okay they're gonna hold up long
enough for me to find somebody no
they're not hey Tom great is always pal
appreciate bye bye
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports